وكيل وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه دفع الله
الحاج علي وجود اي حاجه لمبادرات وساطه
تهدف لحل الازمه في بلاده وفي تصريحات
خاصه بالجزيره في اديس ابابا في مستهل
جوله في دول الايجاد اكد الحاج ان الحكومه
السودانيه قادره على حل الخلافات الداخليه
على حد تعبيره
نحن كما ذكرنا ونؤكد ان هذا النزاع النزاع
الداخلي
نحن لا نرى ان هنالك حاجه لاي من اي جهه
في هذا الوقت ان تتقدم لمبادره خاصه
ببساطه وحل للنزاع الحكومه السودانيه
قادره على ان تضع له حدا قريبا ان شاء
الله
الحاج علي في تصريحات خاصه بالجزيره دول
الجوار او جوار السودان الى تضامن مع
الحكومه والجيش السوداني مشددا على ان عدم
استقرار السودان سيؤثر على الاقليم
واكيد ان السودان هو دوله مهمه
من ناحيه جيوسياسيه
اهميته
للاقليم
واذا حدث فيه لا قدر الله
اي عدم استقرار سيؤثر على كل الاقليم
ويتعدى الاقليم ولذلك
اناشد كل الدول ان تساعد في ان تحافظ على
السودان واستقرار السودان